[Music]
in taxi nightmare news Oh No
uber submitted by where's dad who knows
your dad is you know where your dad no
he's a stepdad that should don't count
it count no it doesn't call dad
I got Mattie Oh Sofia you know sometimes
that's unlike many white people world
dude one day guys this gonna be like
you're not my real dad it's gonna they
always say that it's like it's like it's
like full house sometimes let me go out
though like and people ask me oh is that
your son and I'm a stepson they give me
the craziest look sometimes like as if I
said something wrong really yeah maybe I
don't know maybe I'm not supposed to say
that that's not PC right I guess not oh
no no that's my step what's the piece
like like bison because I'm just
supposed to say I'm the dad I guess I
could pose this like you're separating
yourself yeah I know I know it's down
you're supposed to get choked out how I
feel though a little bit choked up I
think you have to say he's not my
biological son but I love him you got to
get choked up about he got to be like
you know that's not my real son yeah
tell you what society a woman was
horrified after noticing her cab driver
was wasn't wearing any pants take two no
I'm kidding
let's leave it in I like this driver
wasn't wearing pants yeah she was worth
lying
what about underpants we don't know why
oh I'm picturing is like shitty leather
seats with like ball sweat was his a/c
broken yeah cuz then I support this
morning--i person huh you know what's
funny so when you do the opposite right
it's kind of cool like you're shirtless
and then you're just walking around with
pants and then like a male-model could
pull this off or a buff guy or whatever
but the opposite no matter how like you
could get a hot guy you could get like
whatever if he's just wearing a t-shirt
with nothing and his dick is like kind
of peeking down
the shirt like this I know it's terrible
as she's laughing while she says she's
getting the image it looks like a baby
yeah you look like a [ __ ] baby I do
it because I I know how funny it is yep
see you wear a extra-long shirt is that
what's happening no I'm just wearing a
t-shirt
I have nothing no dick is out yes and
it's creeping under the t-shirt yes you
[ __ ] bragger bragging about that [ __ ]
looks funny it's like a baby
yeah we're just socks on yeah yeah it
just sucks and the t-shirt question why
is the passenger even looking down in
the first place well she said she didn't
realize this until 10 minutes into the
ride that's what I'm saying so like
getting out of the a million on an
unknown in hundreds of hundreds many
blades out of the 50 overrides that I've
had yeah I would if you ask me that any
of them not wear pants I wouldn't be
able to answer because I would never
check do you ever sit in the front seat
yes
front and back in sideways never I never
try to look at their broch out of the
millions of out of the thousands like
seven my client has never seen all right
that's believable that's why yeah yeah I
wish a video clip that she took while
she was in the taxi oh that's awkward so
she's a pornographer no no she was just
saying like she was just so appalled
what did he [ __ ] himself and had to
throw away the pen I think but then why
pick up a writer because so this he has
to make money for his starving children
do you think he's like oh sorry I shoot
myself at throw away the pants yeah yeah
so this takes place in China oiled China
doesn't have a burr so they have their
own I did not picture China yeah they
have their own Chinese ride-sharing app
and so she was like some Romanian dude
really hairy late
well she didn't mention she could see
the man's hair like whenever she passes
good taking place at nighttime so when
he's peeking whenever it would drive
past like streetlights she could see the
man's leg hair what was he doing like
jacking off while he was driving we
don't know why and so she didn't bother
to ask she just started filming him
that's a violation I don't actually
asked while she was in the people were
so long
confrontational now she should have just
said why don't you have pants on yeah
was shooting a video this also was
around 2:00 a.m. so I don't know if that
has anything to do with it but perfect
time see of course she's shooting a
video because she wants to show everyone
how crazier life is yeah you know and
talk about it later that's what everyone
does look at me ii am coming back from
the clap and here's the video i'm wild
and crazy oh my god great legs
i thought it was a woman's leg it looks
like that's a great pair of legs
the [ __ ] well isn't China hey Asians
make the best what do you call them what
what do you call drag queens oh yeah
yeah I could have played down but it
just is really loud I mean hair on the
legs there's no hair in the way ya got
to be two inches from that [ __ ] does he
hear that that's like it's hard to see
in the camera is holding a shirt down
and he was holding yes so she'd notice
after 10 minutes in the ride she was
like why is he only driving with one
half he's polite though it's not like
your shirt was up here like he was
covering his junk he could be wearing
very tiny shorts and then it's fine
don't you love that how it's completely
fine if he's wearing very small shorts
yeah like in gold in high school
sometimes they look like they don't have
any pats on they're just walking around
with big ass t-shirts sometimes when I
wear shorts in a jacket it looks like
that so what's she able to see his dick
not reported that she was but it is
reported that she contacted the
ride-sharing company and to complain
about this driver and that they said
that the driver denied her claim that's
not even my leg the company said that
they can't remove him from that
since he didn't admit to it and
apparently sir is that you're like he's
like no that's not the only thing I can
do is reduce the number of orders that
he can take that's the only thing they
could do what I mean
he got her to the destination yeah she
he's trying to cover his dick yeah yeah
he's not like with a dick hanging out
like I get off on [ __ ] doing this
like there's I feel like there's
something yeah maybe he picked up a
hooker cuz it is late at night so we
still had to get his rides on up for
that date she lost all his money for
that day but she left his phone behind
so you can still get right Oh crystal
pants yeah they could they used to you
well the phone's on the dashboard I like
all those right sure people it's always
like - nifty device that holds it like
he got his wallet and he devised the
whole like every other lift you get into
it so it's like Oh where'd you get that
little stand from yeah
did you really give you know like I need
to get one all the cabin extra one I
gave it to you nothing in the car
doesn't too much of a nifty device he
couldn't use it well what would you guys
reactive you would see this
I'm not even checking down there like I
said and my millions or thousands or
fifties or hundreds of rides I've been
and I've never even checked if they're
wearing pants you just happen to see
that your driver will happen to be
peeking yeah I'll be so offended if it's
a guy row if it's a girl either one I'd
be absolutely so offended why I know
because I can't I can't get offended by
anything I swear to god it's like Saul
the [ __ ] what he's wearing tiny little
booty shorts or whatever or maybe he's
like I'm so bored in life I like it's
like it's like a casual Friday if I take
my pants off in here yeah I mean like
for him it's a little different because
he's just doing the same thing all day
good for the guy I did something similar
I was hiking up my shorts
to like be like underwear and I covered
it with my t-shirt when we were going to
the Starbucks drive-through and I'll
like they're gonna see me that is gonna
look like just a t-shirt they didn't
acknowledge him at all he felt stupid
worst pranker in the world
you jes if you're in this car it's 2:00
a.m. you're alone
let's do didn't happen first of all I
wouldn't have gotten in the front seat
she was in the front seat right she's
not front seat in the front really I do
have been my family like whenever there
would be a driver and then everyone sits
in the back seat the driver would always
be like well you're gonna leave me like
a taxi and so I get but I guess like
it's been like I'm conditioned to think
like I shouldn't leave the driver alone
like I was I like the front sometimes
because then I can see more yeah and
then play but I have to talk more yeah
you put your put your stuff in tough
situation where you do have to talk to
the driver when you say in the front not
always they just pull out my phone and
really that's also rude but I leave them
in the front seat you're in the
peripheral vision of each other now you
guys are weirdest part I can't with two
people here admit to sitting in the
front seat in the taxi yeah I don't do
that I like to sit as far away from the
drivers humanly possible yeah I know I
would I would I thank you remember when
you're when you're a kid and you're like
in your neighbor station wagon and it
faces the freaking traffic all the way
but [ __ ] backseat yeah I would rather
sit in there because then I could just
do whatever I want say whatever I want
you know I mean I would feel weird well
no honestly cuz it's always embarrassing
because Nicky [ __ ] little on camera
everywhere
sorry and so no and so I'm always like
oh I just feel like this frozen this
when she whips out the vlog camera and
like there's a text wherever there I'm
always like you know you have every
right to hate us every right but if we
were [ __ ] off like way back away
then it's like II I can I can handle it
yeah so the difference is that you're in
the backseat of an uber versus the front
passenger seat you would feel much more
comfortable to vlog in the back seat
which is only actually the same distance
I'm never comfortable during a blog ever
same ever but but I do it it's fine it's
fun sometimes right but like but it's
the whipping it out thing and not
informing driver like hey sorry we're
gonna film a thing like we're not crazy
people we she doesn't really do that she
just whips it out she's got crazy balls
about that she doesn't whip it out
anywhere grocery store [ __ ] movie
theater she doesn't care like she was
doing it
louis c.k shall we she whipped out of
here Malik she's a she's a meaning
everything and I'm always like this is
so [ __ ] embarrassing oh my god
because I don't I don't know I'm from
I'm from a different uh I'm not here
like I'm against the selfies and all
this [ __ ] I don't like all of it so
you're a stand-up comic you're not a
vlogger you're not a yeah but I'm a
youtuber I mean I understand comic but
I'm known for being a youtuber so I I
accept the title of youtuber because
that's what I am but I just I just have
a problem going [ __ ] kill myself you
do that idea you take small - do you -
you have to get used to that right yeah
because and then you look at your bank
account you're like oh and it makes its
fans happy howdy-do folks thank you so
much for watching don't forget to
subscribe to stay up on their most
recent upload and any other cool content
that we put up there and hit the
subscribe button for the last video
click up here